[Music]
all right let's go out to Montgomery
Alabama and talk to Help Me Rhonda Help
Help Me Rhonda what's
up hey Dr John how are you good I'm
pretty much over caffeinated this
morning I'm a little bit uh I I can I
can tell a little bit I was snorting it
off my counter so what's up nice well um
I'm totally fangirling right now first
of all because I have so much respect
for you so when I thought I needed to
talk to somebody about this topic you
are the first person that came to my
mind well that makes me feel that makes
it feel good thank you you're welcome um
so my husband is in a job that um the
job is um very fulfilling for him but
the management is horrible and therefore
it makes him in a horrible mood um and
it's literally started stting to affect
our marriage and I don't know what to do
to help oo okay can I blow up this whole
Paradigm sure all right um are you
comfortable saying what his job
is um he is a maintenance supervisor for
a large religious
organization oh he works for Jesus that
gets dicey all right okay so and you
should know a preacher kid too this
might play into what your does 1,00% it
does yeah oh that makes it even easier
so here's what we're going to
do there are I'm just going to say men
but I know there's men and women okay
but for this case I'm just going to use
the word men so everybody just take 30
40% off okay men go to war men clean
sewers men clean body parts off of
walls men um are proctologists
men give
colonoscopies um right they do all sorts
of
things and I know women do all those
things too okay but in this case we're
talking about your
husband the problem is not doing the job
it's not even the management of his
job I don't want to blame the job or his
boss for how he chooses to treat his
family
and how he chooses to treat
himself now here's where that gets
really uncomfortable inside a home it's
actually I'm already uncomfortable I
know you know why because it's easier
for you you can sleep better at night
blaming his
boss but it's real tough to sleep when
you go oh wait a minute you're making
this
choice and so I think we have had this
Collective
whacko w wo um idea over the last decade
last 15 years simply because we've had
some wild economic um like uh windfalls
right just we've created wealth over the
last well we've borrowed it actually but
we've created wealth over the last 10 15
years it never existed in the in the
world right and so because of that we've
started blaming all of our uncomfortable
moments on the job how hard it is it's
to the boss is mean bosses have always
been mean
what suddenly changed is people stopped
doing the things that they needed to do
to be well when they walked in that
front
door see what I'm saying oh yeah
so if you go the problem is
not how hard his job is the problem is
not how much of a jerk his boss is I'll
get to the jerk bosses in a minute okay
because that is a problem I don't want
to blow over that but I want to put the
way he treats his family and ultimately
his bad
mood that's his to
own and that's terrifying for you I do
not want that to be true but it is
true his boss is not walking in the
front door and slamming things and
screaming at you and cracking open a
beer and saying hey I don't even care
that's not his boss that's your husband
now in all fairness he does not do that
he's just super grumpy I'm just I'm just
I'm just making it up it' probably be
better if he did have a beer right he
might be less grumpy all the time maybe
so my question is what is grumpy
protecting him
from and the sad hard part about this
call is you can't answer that only he
can you're
correct well I don't know I wouldn't
know how to answer that right and it
probably goes back to he's seeing how
the sausage is made at a at a religious
organization his whole
life M and if you work back there for a
long time and you um don't do things to
protect your soul it can get real
gnarly uhuh right it can it can wear you
down here's whose fault that is not his
wife he does not get a pass on treating
his wife with disrespect or being grumpy
period period he doesn't and here's more
important he doesn't get to create a
home that his kids don't want to come
home
to Simply EMP neers well so they're not
coming back are they no that's right no
that's
right one of my chief transitions as an
adult one of the things that I did a
control alt delete on was I want to
create a home full of warmth and
laughter and memories so that my kids
always want to come back MH and that
means and and by the way I work in a
really difficult job I play it off and
laugh a lot um but my job's hard and
it's got tons of travel and tons of
midnight meet and greets and 600 a.m.
meet and greets after like it's hard
it's a tough job plus hey write a book
in the H it's tough and that means it's
my
job to make sure I'm seeing a counselor
to make sure I'm exercising I'm eating
right I sleep which means I can't eat
certain things cuz if I eat certain
things I don't sleep last night I was
exhausted and I went with my buddy
Michael and George camel and a couple
others we went to a comedy show I
actually wanted to go to bed but I knew
my body needed to hang out with my
friends and laugh really hard with some
great guys right I got to do those
things so I walk in my front
door and end up with a morning like I
had this morning I was very very tired
but me and my daughter played the
funniest spin around the you see what
I'm saying mhm I do those things so that
I'm not grump y it's not my boss's fault
it's not my job's fault it's mine so may
I ask a follow-up question you got it um
so this is my third marriage okay we've
been married eight years um I we were
both in long-term marriages like I had a
practice one that lasted a short while
and then we both had long marriages and
now we're married each other for eight
years okay and I can't help but
feel that his mood is directed toward me
even though rationally I know that it's
not so what can I do for myself so I'm
going to ask you hard questions is that
okay
yeah what kind of environment have you
created for him to come home
to loving I hope well let's put let's
put loving aside I want to talk about
feelings when he opens that door does
the house feel
hilarious and fun and oh my gosh I'm so
glad you're here or is at a loving house
he opens the door and it's like hey put
don't put your shoes inside this
house do not bring that bag in here
gross get that
out
um so I'm not listen I'm not saying that
he needs he he should bring his shoes in
right I I see what you're saying um
probably a little bit of both I am super
happy to see him but then it's you know
I got I got to get dinner done needs to
come in the house the right way
right yeah I need him to I need him to
behave so I don't have to worry about
that in addition to everything else and
nothing makes me more grumpy than when
my mom starts lecturing me I knew you
were gonna say
that I knew you were gonna say that quit
being his
mom quit being his mom what does that
mean hey that doesn't mean that he just
Stomps mud through the house mhm M what
that means
is you take him out for breakfast and
you say hey we're 8 years in I want this
to be my ride or die you are my ride or
die and he is I know when you bring mud
in the house like when that when the
house is unclean I feel
unsafe I feel like I'm failing you I
feel like I'm failing our marriage I
feel like I got one job and I'm not
doing it right it honors me when that's
different than I told you
right or even if you didn't say don't
say the words I told you he can feel
that tone all over your body language
when you go pick up his shoes and throw
them out on the front
porch and again I'm just making stuff up
right um yes it also
is if you tell him that and this is a
common thing that again I'm totally
generalizing here please people who
listen to this don't blow me up in the
comments I know it goes both ways I
know but often
a wife may go after her husband's job
which in a strange way goes after his
identity and he has to either shut the
conversation down or defend
himself because he might might be even
more true with the preachers kids that's
right he might see himself working a job
under a tyrant because he works unto
God and part of his calling since he was
zero years old is to have a miserable
life on behalf of something bigger than
himself so that everybody else can wor
it
right wow uhuh and
so there's a different thing if you sit
down and go your job is killing you yada
y that's different
then um I love you and I can't tell you
when I just think about your life how
proud I am of you that you've given up
every Sunday for your entire life to
serve other people so they can have have
an an experience of meeting God and I
don't want you to Die
Young I don't want you to have heart
attack I want you to walk in this house
and be so happy and joyful to walk in
here can we create that
world that's a very different he doesn't
that's an invitation it's not he doesn't
have to defend
himself and when you say you're just
being grumpy that's really vague
language I want you to be very very
specific when
you
yell it scares me to death when I get
the sense from your body that you don't
want me near you I always want you near
me that's F right there that's what I'm
talking about you see what I'm saying
the way exactly the way my wife put it
was John you have a nuclear reactor in
your chest and I can all a whole house
can feel
[Music]
it and we all want to come come closer
to you but your body's telling us to get
away and I had to go deal with that I
had to go sit with the counselor and say
some hard hard hard
stuff and like happened this morning I'm
starting to say a new sentence that I
haven't said ever and that was to my
daughter Josephine get off me I gotta go
to
work because she can't stop being around
me now because that reactor's
disassembled I still get mad I still get
frustrated good grief I'm not a robot
but man that sense of peace calm
radiates out of my body not that sense
of get away from
me but if he's going to a boss that
belittles him and he has parents that
he's still trying to live up
to and he's been a preachers kid his
whole life so every time he goes to the
bathroom he has to do it just right or
somebody's going to comment on
it and then he comes home to more
criticism man that's a tough
road is that fair
that yeah that
yeah it is um it kind of turned into a
self-fulfilling prophecy because he fan
of yours as well and when I told him
that you and I had an appointment to
talk his demeer
changed so I think he saw that it was
serious enough to me that I needed help
yeah and because he loves me he's making
a greater effort um this last but let's
don't make him do an effort over and
above your criticism and your disdain
and you're patting him on the head as my
gross little boy that just needs to do
it
right I don't like to think that that's
what I do you might not you might not
but ask him do you feel like I belittle
you do you feel like when you come home
you have yet another boss that you can't
make happy because if so I'm so
sorry I'm trying to that's a good
question I'm trying here's the I've
talked about this uh more recently um
publicly for the first time here's the
question that changed my
marriage how do me and my wife want our
home to feel like when we walk in the
front
door for her here's a couple of things
that she asked me to do through tears we
live way out in the country she said
when you get home before me and it's
dark will you turn the porch lights on
so I can see it for we have like a mile
long driveway or quarter mile long
driveway can you turn the porch lights
on it makes me feel like the home is
well our house is welcome me home will
you clean up all these piles everywhere
cuz I walk home and there's piles
everywhere and I inhale real sharply
versus exhaling and dropping my
shoulders now a clean house isn't a mom
scolding a little boy for me a clean
house is me telling my wife I love
you and for her I asked when I come home
I need 10 or 15 minutes before you start
asking questions about hey what do we do
and what about this and did you get this
paid and I just need meant to come in
and my preference would be if we could
just hug right when I walk in the
door mhm and dude she is
amazing and I love hearing my kids run
around yelling like see see what I'm
saying we created the house that we
wanted we wanted to feel and then we had
to reverse engineer what does that mean
right and that might mean honey when you
get home I want the house to feel I I
want I want you to walk in that door so
bad
and if you're tense from your last
meeting when you walk in it's my it
scares my
body my body goes into protection not
into
invitation and he can say all right I'll
get off of work and I'll go to the gym
for 30 minutes and just walk on a
treadmill I'll go walk around the
park I'll exhale I'll pray I'll listen
to a podcast I'll do whatever I need to
do so that I walk in and my shoulders
are dropped right that's a totally
different world we're talking about
and by the way I don't think either of
you are bad I don't I know this this is
not the job's fault real quick before I
I get off the call here toxic E I hate
the word toxic now it's just so beat
down Bad Bosses ruin people destroy
people makes it very hard to stay above
water and so um I'm calling on bosses
all over the country to stop sucking
stop start loving the people that you
work with and by the way if you love the
people who work for you and who are
trying to help people out of the
marketplace and you love them back and
instead of saying I told but instead you
say hey man how can I serve you and get
this done we have a deadlines you got to
show up and work you got to go Full Tilt
how can I support you and how can I love
you in this
position you will serve more customers
and you'll make more customers happy you
will help them in their day-to-day lives
which is what business should be about
and you'll make more
money but bad leaders man if you use
your arrogance and your strength and
your position of power to beat up on
people shame on you
dude you're going to collapse your
business because you create a business
of people who don't want to make
mistakes not a business of people who
want to love customers
well Bad Bosses
choose as for me in my house we're going
to choose to love people and take care
of them and demand excellence and we're
going to go help people make that how
you practice too thanks for the call Ron
you're
awesome